[Music]
morbius is a marvel character who's been
an important part of the universe
he's brilliant acure
it's funnily possible a strong
he's got some unique powers
but his powers seem to be out of his
control
what's happening
i love the opportunity to do something
transformational i've become something
different
it was a very intense physical role
more viasat is most frail and then most
monstrous
this superhero super villain
putting a new marvel character on screen
that had never been on screen before and
it'll be fun to see where we could go
with that there's a web of opportunity
more bs exclusively in movie theaters
tomorrow
michael
i've known you since you were a child
you were gift
you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
[Music]
i should have died years ago
why am i still here not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
increase strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
is an overpowering urge to consume blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael murby
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing
what's up
[Music]
you